Oh,
the Al Gore film is uh,
something that scared a lot of people,
but it was also very widely dismissed by a lot of other people as well.
How accurate was that movie?
I think it proved to be too sanguine it like it didn't deal with a lot of
extreme weather.
I thought that stuff was far away.
And I think this is one of the,
one of the big shortcomings of most writing about climate,
most
kind of communication about climate for 25 years is that we were told it was
slow.
We were told it was going to be coming maybe at the scale of centuries,
something we'd have to worry about for our grandchildren.
But when you realize that half of all the damage we've done has been done in the
last 30 years and you see already the extreme weather.
We had a global,
he waved last summer,
totally unprecedented.
People died in Canada.
They died in Russia.
They died in the Middle East.
The same season.
3 million people were evacuated in China from a typhoon,
unprecedented rains in Japan.
We had multiple hurricanes in the Caribbean all at once.
There was an island in Hawaii,
east island,
a small island,
not one that most people have gone to,
but God literally wiped off the map by a hurricane.
They're thinking about inventing a new category of hurricane category six.
All of these impacts,
um,
were,
are coming much faster than scientists predicted even a decade or two ago.
And so I think the first inconvenient truth is a little too complacent,
but Al Gore is also,
you know,
I know him a little bit.
I've talked to him a few times.
He's,
I'm temperamentally,
he's a technocrat,
he's an optimist.
He thinks market forces can solve all this stuff and I don't even totally
disagree with him.
Um,
I think that market forces are really powerful.
We've had a huge green energy revolution in the u s that's,
you know,
and had spillover effects elsewhere in the world.
So solar powers now cheaper than anybody expected it would be decade or two ago.
Although it's also the case that we haven't replaced any of our dirty energy
with it.
We've just added to our capacity.
So the ratio of renewable energy to dirty energy is now the same as it was 40
years ago.
We made no progress.
Um,
why is that?
Because we just,
if we're like,
rather than saying,
oh,
let's retire this coal plant and replace it with it,
um,
you know,
a wind farm,
we think,
oh,
we'll have the coal plant and the wind farm will have more energy.
You know,
we just grow the pie of energy.